momento de hablar de economía france24 y
por ello le doy la bienvenida a mi
compañero luís méndez luis iniciamos en
eeuu porque el presidente de joe biden
impulsó sus proyectos de ley de
infraestructura y el paquete de gastos
así es andrés e éstos están valorados en
un millón y dos billones de dólares
respectivamente
pese scranton su pueblo natal bayrén
destacó que la ley de infraestructura
restauraría de eeuu que requiere de
inversiones en sus trabajadores familia
y medio ambiente adicionalmente agregó
que estas iniciativas buscan expandir
los servicios sociales escuchemos
estos proyectos no se tratan de
izquierda versus derecha moderado versus
progresista o cualquier cosa que
enfrente a un estadounidense con otros
estos proyectos tienen que ver con la
competitividad versus la complacencia se
trata de ampliar las oportunidades se
trata de liderar al mundo y dejarlo
pasar y por cierto no aumentarán ni un
centavo al déficit
is one tengo planes desde hace por otro
lado el gobernador de california gavin
newsom quien firmó una orden ejecutiva
para descongestionar los principales
puertos del estado hay que destacar que
los puertos de los ángeles y long beach
ambos en california reciben alrededor
del 40 por ciento de los contenedores
que ingresan a estados unidos la orden
ejecutiva entre otras cosas ordena a las
agencias estatales a buscar terrenos
para el almacenamiento de contenedores
louis pasamos ahora a europa porque el
fm destacó el crecimiento económico por
el continente lo hizo durante la entrega
del informe regional donde afirmó que el
continente presentará un crecimiento de
5,2 por ciento para este año dentro de
las economías llamadas avanzadas y por
otro lado será de 6% entre las economías
definidas como emergentes esto significa
un alza de 0,3 y de 11 por ciento más
que el informe revelado en julio pasado
el organismo también se refirió a la
inflación y sobre ello la oficina de
estadísticas de la zona euro informó
este miércoles que el indicador cerró
con un alza de 3 por ciento a tasa anual
mientras que a nivel mensual fue de 0 5%
dentro de los países de la zona euro
louis el banco de desarrollo para
américa latina anunció la colocación de
mil millones de dólares en bonos éstos
serán empleados para mantener el
acompañamiento en los planes
reactivación social y económica en donde
los países que operan de acuerdo con el
organismo en un comunicado esta
institución señala que estos bonos
tendrán un vencimiento de tres años
asimismo agrega que entre los
inversionistas destacan administradores
de fondos e instituciones públicas y
otros con distribución geográfica en
europa medio oriente áfrica asia y
américa por otro lado en parte del
comunicado se destacó que hoy más que
nunca américa latina' nos necesite
estamos atrayendo recursos a tasas
favorables para apoyar a los gobiernos
los planes de atención así se lee en
parte del comunicado y ahora vamos a
argentina porque se mantienen las
disputas en torno a la medida de precios
congelados esta fue oficializada el día
de hoy con la aparición en el boletín
oficial pero ha dejado molestias en el
sector o en una parte del sector
empresarial del país que ha vuelto y
esta vez de parte de la cámara de
comerciantes a amenazar con el
desabastecimiento de productos por su
parte el secretario de comercio interior
roberto feletti rechazó las afirmaciones
e indicó que argentina trata de salir
adelante con el esfuerzo de todos para
volverla definitivamente social y
económicamente sostenible por otro lado
la cámara argentina de comercio se
excusó de su comentario y estableció que
la iniciativa privada constituye la
mejor estrategia no sólo para combatir
la inflación sino también para alcanzar
el desarrollo económico louis en
sudáfrica crece la expectativa por la
presencia de gas helio este gas es muy
conocido por su uso para rellenar globos
pero tiene un destacado papel en escáner
médico superconductores y en la
industria de viajes espaciales de
acuerdo con la agencia afp se
encontraron reservas de este gas en
sudáfrica del 2 al 4 por ciento y puede
haber reservas con la concentración del
12% para tener una idea en eeuu este gas
que suele verse mezclado con el gas
natural se presente en concentraciones
de hasta 0 3% según la firma es decir el
market el mercado del helio en 2019 tuvo
un valor de 10 mil 600 millones de
dólares vamos a ver los indicadores
cerraron de manera mixta en eeuu donde
se mostró la caída de el nasdaq
compuesto en europa fueron positivos los
cierres a lo largo de las jornadas ya
abrió el mercado japonés con una ligera
caída en américa latina hubo cierres
mixtos a lo largo de la jornada louis
muchas gracias por la información
económica es todo por el momento
quédense con nosotros
[Música]
y